hello there guys so very recently we
just got a new rumor
that apparently lucasfilm is planned in
multiple projects for darth bane
so according to insider daniel rickman's
patreon
disney has plans for multiple projects
including darth bane potentially
including a solo project
it's unknown if these projects would be
released as movies or as disney plus
series
so if you guys don't know who darth bane
is he is one of the first
sith lords and lived about a thousand
years before the clone wars
he is most famous for establishing the
rule of two where there can only be one
sith master and an apprentice at a time
also he actually appeared in the clone
wars tv show as a specter
and i think he was actually voiced by
mark hamill which is pretty cool
anyway guys so this is a rumor it's
possible we may not even
see him in a live action format it's
possible he may be showcased in a novel
or comic form in the high republic era
but honestly i would really love a
disney plus series about darth bane
where it shows the earlier days of the
sith
and him establishing the rule of two you
know i think we could get a lot of added
law stuff which would really add to the
new star wars canon
um i don't think we'll get a movie about
a miscella movie
because disney wasn't really pleased
with how solo performed at the box
office
which is a shame because i thought it
was a really good movie
but anyway that's about it for this
video again it's just a rumor but it's
still interesting and i hope it's true i
think it'll be quite cool to see
anyway my question of the day to you
guys is would you guys want to see a
darth bane series if so what would you
like to see included in it
anyway that's about it for this video so
i'll catch you guys in the next one
[Music]
you